bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
cette semaine je vous emmène en
extérieur à la découverte de quelques
unes des animations proposées à
l'occasion des fêtes de Pâques dans
quelques instants nous partirons au
château de Breteuil pour une grande
chasse aux œufs mais pour l'heure
direction France Miniature ou le
chocolat est à la fête Marianne edwyer
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
responsable de la communication et du
marketing au parc de France Miniature
alors vous avez l'habitude de présenter
pour les familles des ateliers
thématiques et là l'occasion de Pâques
vous allez nous faire découvrir le monde
du chocolat alors qu'est-ce qui va se
passer exactement ce week-end alors pour
le week-end de Pâques donc les samedis
19 dimanche 20 et lundi 21 avril ces
trois après-midi là nous allons
accueillir sur le parc une association
qui s'appelle le salon du chocolatier
qui propose aux visiteurs aux enfants en
priorité de découvrir le chocolat sous
forme d'ateliers alors ce sera un
atelier il y a une petite partie
découverte qui se décidera à tous les
publics les ateliers seront davantage
réservés aux enfants la partie
découverte mais on va nous montrer que
le chocolat ça vient d'une fève que la
fève elle est hébergée dans une Cabotte
on va nous expliquer où ça pousse
comment on récolte toute l'histoire du
cacao voilà assez rapidement et très
vite on va aller pratiquer donc on
propose des ateliers à partir de 14h sur
les trois dates du week-end de Pâques
des ateliers qui durent à peu près une
demi-heure et où on va proposer aux
enfants de manipuler différentes
ganaches donc ils vont rouler dans leur
main ils vont s'en mettre partout et on
s'amuser beaucoup avec ça moi
chocolatier de vrais chocolatiers des
ganaches au lait noir ou chocolat blanc
qui vont ensuite rouler dans de la coco
ou du cacao et puis partir avec leur
petit ballotin de chocolat qui seront
réalisés eux-mêmes comme des vrais
chocolatiers ici à France Miniature et
donc c'est sans oublier évidemment le
parcours de la France au travers de ces
régions et de ses villages l'atelier est
sans supplément au prix d'entrée rée
donc on invite tout le monde donc à
venir et qu'elle ne Pâques merci
beaucoup Marion et dire merci
bonjour Henri Françoise Breteuil bonjour
Elia alors vous êtes le propriétaire du
château de Breteuil et vous nous
accueillez parce que nous allons parler
du week-end de Pâques dimanche et lundi
les sous-bois donc du parc vont s'animer
de façon particulière est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en parler et bien c'est
toujours une grande fête à Breteuil le
dimanche et le lundi de Pâques puisque
ce sont les célèbres chasse aux œufs où
nous avons à peu près 15000 œufs qui au
cours de ces deux journées vont être
cachées au cours de deux chasse aux œufs
par jour une à 12h30 et l'autre à 5
heures de l'après-midi avec des œufs en
couleur qui devront être retrouvés
assemblés et en fonction de cela les
enfants qui ont trouvé ces œufs en
question
recevront en cadeau un oeuf ou plusieurs
œufs en chocolat
et puis nous aurons également un atelier
qui fait par Sophie qui est une habituée
du château Sophie Morel qui elle va
faire un atelier de peinture sur les
œufs de Pâques pour apprendre aux gens à
les décorer alors il y a également les
animations traditionnelles que l'on
retrouve donc au château de Breteuil les
séances de compte de Charles Perrault le
jeu de piste dans les jardins mais cette
année également vous proposer pour ce
week-end pour les visiteurs une vraie
découverte une vraie surprise là encore
autour des scènes de contes vous pouvez
nous en parler oui nous avons ce jour-là
3 scène de compte trois fois la conteuse
va raconter des scènes de Charles
Perrault à deux heures trois heures et
4h et à 3h de l'après-midi tout ça les
deux jours dimanche et lundi de Pâques
ce sera ce seront des comptes des
jardins donc ça c'est une première
nouveauté une première surprise et puis
l'autre surprise c'est les deux scènes
qui sont maintenant
réaliser en sorte de son et lumière
grâce à Christophe Leray qui a réalisé
les décors les dialogues et la
réalisation complète de ces deux scènes
l'une c'est le petit Japon rouge dans la
petite maison dans la forêt et l'autre
c'est la Belle au bois dormant dans sa
chambre qui dort dans le château et qui
va maintenant se réveiller en musique et
en lumière pour nos visiteurs bien
écoutez merci beaucoup pour toutes ces
explications merci à vous et à très vite
d'autres chasse aux œufs sont organisés
près de chez vous dimanche par exemple
vous pourrez vous rendre à la ferme de
Gally à Saint-Cyr-l'École ou encore dans
le parc du château de Rambouillet
dimanche et lundi ce sont les jardins du
château de Thoiry ou des œufs surpris se
cacheront dans lesquels des passeports
d'entrée illimité pour toute la saison
retrouvons sans plus attendre Nicolas
Gervais pour sa chronique dans le
kiosque
professeur de khmer auteur conférencière
c'est la spécialiste du balai royal du
Cambodge un ballet qui seront spectacle
le 4 mai à la Meuse à Trappes voici ce
piano dans le kiosque
et tout sauf une danse c'est d'abord une
offrande c'est un rituel c'est un rituel
qui existe depuis
des centaines d'années on ne sait pas
quand est-ce que cet art est arrivé au
Cambodge mais on sait que le Cambodge a
été influencé par l'Inde et c'est l'Inde
qui a importé son concept de théâtre
total c'est de la danse mais c'est aussi
de la mine c'est aussi de la musique
des chants donc c'est tout un ensemble
avec un vocabulaire gestuel très
compliqué le rime que c'est le Ramayana
cambodgien ça veut dire la gloire de
Rama
c'est une histoire qui raconte justement
les hauts faits du héros qui s'appelle
Rama et en cambodgien on le désigne sous
le nom de Riem voilà c'est ça c'est la
gloire de Riem donc il est au fait du
héros
certains gestes vont dire que quelque
chose c'est à dire certains gestes
veulent
signifie un sentiment d'autres
précisent une action
disons on peut comparer à à des mots
donc si vous changez la place des mots
vous formez une nouvelle phrase mais
vous avez aussi les champs qui précisent
l'action
lorsque la Révolution de mer Rouge est
arrivée au Cambodge toute la population
a souffert de ce régime sanguinaire
pratiquement un quart de la population a
disparu c'est à dire 2 millions sur les
8 millions de personnes et le résultat
est encore plus dramatique chez les
artistes du palais royal presque 82% des
artistes ont disparu
donc
l'art de cette armillionnaire a vraiment
failli disparaître et au lendemain
de la fin du régime des kinés rouges
il n'y avait plus que 7 professeurs il y
a une grande partie bien sûr de cette
héritage qui a disparu
au Cambodge il faut à peu près 10 ans de
formation pour devenir une bonne
danseuse alors quand il s'agit de des
premiers rôles il faut encore beaucoup
plus de travail il n'y a que des femmes
parce que c'est un théâtre de femmes
c'est quand même un fait particulier au
Cambodge et aussi en Thaïlande c'est à
dire que cet art a été créé par les
femmes et pour les femmes parce que à la
cour du roi il n'y avait que les femmes
les les hommes n'avaient pas accès
au palais royal donc c'était les femmes
qui
régentaient le palais et c'était elle
qui avait conservé cette arme et les
nerf qui avait enrichi et qui a transmis
aux femmes
dans cette histoire de gamecake il y a
les trois personnages importants c'est à
dire le prince c'est dans son épouse et
après qui est son frère et puis vous
avez les deux
personnages non humains c'est-à-dire le
géant Ravana et bien sûr le singe
général des armées halouman qui est un
singe blanc et qui est doué de pouvoir
extraordinaire
c'est la première fois où le théâtre
royal intègre le théâtre d'ombre dans
son jeu la princesse ne redame bupra de
vie a voulu intégrer
le théâtre dont le jeu des acteurs alors
il va y avoir un
très subtil mélange entre les champs qui
appartiennent au Palais Royal et les
champs qui appartiennent au théâtre au
théâtre d'ombres on appelle le SMIC room
parce que smile ça veut dire le cuir 30
ça faisait grand parce que on a deux
genres de théâtre d'ombres le théâtre
d'ombre avec des petits cuirs et le
théâtre d'ombre avec les grands cuir et
le théâtre d'ombre avec le grand cuit
qui s'appelle Mike home et spécialisé
dans le rime que justement dans le jeu
du RMC
et c'est un
pareil c'est un théâtre sacré qui se
joue lors de cérémonies parce que le RMC
est une histoire sacrée
celui qui manie le cuir est aussi un
danseur parce que il faut savoir
danser avec le rythme de la musique on
ne fait on ne fait pas bouger le cuir
comme ça il y a des musiques spécifiques
la princesse nous rendons pas de vie a
réussi en 2003 à faire classer d'abord
le balai royal en tant que patrimoine
immatériel de l'humanité par l'UNESCO et
deux ans après ce fut autour du
ninkswagen le théâtre d'ombre vous allez
voir deux théâtres millénaires
et après le balai Royal on retrouve la
reine Aurélien
cette semaine notre professionnelle du
cinéma est Bertrand Pignier responsable
du cinéma Les Yeux d'Elsa à
Saint-Cyr-l'École il nous livre son coup
de coeur bonjour le coup de cœur au
cinéma les yeux d'Alsace cette semaine
c'est un coup de cœur qui aura lieu dans
une petite semaine de plus c'est une
soirée spéciale cinéma et rock'n roll
qui vous proposera de découvrir deux
groupes de la zone Saint-Quentin
Versailles de groupes d'amateurs
d'amateurs de très bons amateurs mais
d'amateurs tout de même qui joueront
juste avant chacun un film alors il y
aura les amis du rare qui jouent des
standards des années 60 70 des standards
américains qui joueront devant fantôme
of the Paradise le grand film de un des
grands films de Brian De Palma restaurer
restaurer au niveau du son et de l'image
et qui ressort voilà la qui est
ressortie il y a deux mois et que donc
nous aurons pour une projection unique
et puis ensuite
vous aurez un deuxième concert un
concert du du Power Panthers exclusive
Big Band qui est explosif comme son nom
l'indique et qui jouera avant un autre
film mythique une légende du cinéma et
du rock n' roll qui s'appelle this is
Spinal Tap alors ceux qui le connaissent
vont faire waouh ceux qui le connaissent
pas vont se demander de quoi on parle
c'est une sorte de faux documentaire sur
un groupe de rock qui n'existe pas
vraiment mais qui a quand même fait des
concerts c'est une sorte de vaste
pantalonnade extrêmement drôle avec des
musiciens de très très grand talents
donc une soirée exceptionnelle qui aura
lieu le samedi 26 avril à partir de 20h
accueille dans la salle et ensuite c'est
parti pour
6 heures de concert de musique et de
grands moments de rock n' roll et de
cinéma passés ensemble notre émission
est à présent terminée merci de nous
avoir suivi sur tvfils je vous retrouve
donc la semaine prochaine en direct et
en plateau à 18h30 à mercredi